- Women surfers have been
marketed very sexually.
You see a girl in a string
bikini or a g-string standing
on a beach, but when we go out there
it's totally different.
We're wearing full suits
and hoods and booties
and we're not trying to be sexy.
We're going out there to become stronger,
better, more awesome humans.
Big wave surfing is really ferocious.
People have said that women can't surf it,
but I do.
(upbeat music)
I'm Bianca Valenti and I'm a professional
Big Wave Surfer in San
Francisco, California.
11 years ago is when I first
surfed in San Francisco.
I nearly drowned.
And that is when I decided I wanted to put
in the time in and out of
the water and start training
to prepare and ride big waves.
The water in San Francisco
is really really cold.
Sometimes there's even ice
on the sand in the morning
and when it's super cold
you're hands are tingly.
You have to have a really thick skin
and you have to be very
driven, determined,
and motivated because this isn't Hawaii.
Mavericks is a surf spot
where gigantic waves break.
It's been called the
Mount Everest of surfing
and it is located 20 minutes
south of San Francisco.
An average size wave
is three to four feet.
Mavericks starts breaking at 15 feet
and there's been waves
ridden there up to 100 feet.
People have died surfing Mavericks.
It is serious business.
It is for experts only.
There's excitement,
there's fear, adrenaline,
nervousness, happiness.
It's really every emotion at once.
When I hear somebody say that
women are not strong enough
or good enough to surf big waves,
I just start laughing because
it makes me feel alive
and I love it.
It's about challenging yourself.
It's about persevering
and overcoming obstacles
and so it's a much deeper
experience for me personally
and that's why I embrace
surfing in San Francisco.
(upbeat music)